this video is brought to you by
betterhelp
[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about the website that has irreparably
damaged every nook and cranny of my
fragile brain twitter and while we're on
the topic of things that are objectively
bad for me that i can't look away from
let's also talk about elon musk because
along with solving the energy crisis
building colonies on mars and and naming
a baby x has decided to use some of his
fortune to purchase the aforementioned
hell site
www.twitter.com now it's not uncommon
for rich people to buy outrageous things
so naturally the internet responded to
this purchase and a totally rational way
no just kidding everyone lost every they
just lost their minds and enough twitter
users straight up deleted their accounts
in protest such that some folks were
wondering if elon had already started to
wield his powers to drain their
followers others were treated to
instagram a part of meta which is owned
by this guy so were people right to
freak out about musk's twitter bid can
he use the platform for some type of
evil or is the internet always in need
of its main antagonist and musk just
happens to fit the bill and should we
not be using products owned by dudes who
might be bad does any of this really
matter let's find out in this wise crag
edition will elon ruin twitter and a
quick note before we get into it buying
one of the major tech platforms isn't
like buying a new couch transactions on
the scale involve board members and
stocks and lawyers and lots and lots of
money which all take lots of time so at
the time of this recording elon musk
does not officially own twitter and the
deal could still fall through and if it
does merely consider this a thought
experiment but before we dive in we want
to thank betterhelp who's sponsoring
this video in honor of mental health
awareness month that's right may is a
month dedicated to raising awareness
providing support and fighting the
stigma against mental health struggles
this year's theme is together for mental
health which encourages people to share
personal stories in hopes of making
everyone feel empowered to prioritize
their mental health
so here i'll go first
i grew up in a family that wasn't really
open about mental health and emotions so
it wasn't until much later in life that
i was able to reach out to a therapist
and once i did i realized that i'd been
depressed for a lot of years but finally
being in therapy and opening up and
having someone tell me that what i was
feeling was okay and that there was ways
to approach this was really a
life-changing situation so
i for one wouldn't be where i am today
without therapy and i really encourage
anyone who's feeling that type of way to
seek it out for themselves now another
goal of mental health awareness month is
to improve access to mental health
services which has been one of better
help's goals from the start regardless
of your location this customized therapy
platform allows you to communicate with
your therapist through your choice of
video phone and or live chat sessions so
if you're not in the mood to be on video
no problem plus better health offers
unlimited messaging so you can contact
your therapist anytime and as often as
you like because betterhelp's network
has over 20 000 therapists from a
variety of backgrounds it's easy to find
one whose expertise suits your unique
needs but it's easy and free to change
therapists if you don't hit it off once
you sign up for better help and fill out
a detailed questionnaire you can start
communicating with your therapist within
48 hours it's not a crisis line and it's
not self-help it's professional therapy
done confidentially and securely online
plus it's more affordable than
traditional in-person therapy hsa
benefits are accepted and financial aid
is available so if you're struggling
with your mental health try better help
today or if someone you know is really
going through it try suggesting better
help to them visit betterhelp.com
wisecrack to join the over 2 million
people already taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional and when you go
to betterhelp.com wisecrack you'll get
10 percent off your first month that's
betterhelp.comwisecrack
and now back to the show now before we
figure out if the musk buys twitter
outrage is warranted we need to take a
brief detour through the analog era
because while old-timey rich men didn't
know the difference between a dogecoin
and a benifer they did know the power of
owning the means of cultural and
journalistic production for more on this
see the quaint indie film citizen kane
dudes like william randolph hearst the
inspiration for citizen kane used the
newspapers they owned to push their own
agenda this allowed them to do things
like garner national support for a war
hearst was partial to the
spanish-american variety or simply to
seek revenge against their industry
rivals for the ultra-rich of the early
20th century owning a newspaper was
basically like having a personal
megaphone eventually feeling like their
voices still weren't quite loud enough
the hearst of the world began acquiring
entire chains of newspapers to further
propagate their beliefs but in the
post-world war ii era things like
journalistic integrity and editorial
independence became trendy and the idea
of a rich old dude that lived in a
castle owning all the newspapers started
to seem a bit gauche and american
journalism lived happily ever after
right
right right it did it lived happily ever
after
yeah not really to say nothing about the
fleecing of american newsrooms pivots to
video and the push from news to content
in the past decades we are once again
living through an era of super rich
people owning media outlets and also an
era of really good tv shows about super
rich dudes owning media outlets why
shouldn't we do all the news why
shouldn't we do all the news well kim
jong pap because that's not how things
work in this country speaking of
television's favorite father figure the
real life inspiration for logan roy is
none other than rupert murdoch whose
company news corp heads up hundreds of
news and media outlets around the world
including your uncle rod's favorite
channel fox news and much like his
on-screen counterpart murdoch has been
accused of various misdeeds from hacking
the phones of journalists and
celebrities to straight up using his
media empire to manipulate the national
political discourse and murdoch isn't
alone the ex-husband of noted
philanthropist mackenzie scott
[Music]
born in 1964. jeffrey bezos threw down
250 million dollars to acquire the
washington post in 2013. bezos's
billionaire frenemy salesforce ceo mark
benioff snatched up ownership of time
magazine in 2018 and the emerson
collective an organization run by widow
of steve jobs lauren powell jobs snagged
a major stake in the atlantic meanwhile
the la times san diego union tribune and
a number of smaller community papers
were purchased by biotech billionaire
patrick soon chiong for 500 million
dollars i don't believe you the liberal
media would have told me about this
there's no such thing the new york times
is owned by nyt incorporated which is
owned by altheon ballistic dynamics
which is owned by the murdoch family who
are owned
by halliburton
so as you can see musk's bid for twitter
is far from the first time that a rich
one percenter purchased a media company
maybe for the purpose of directing media
narratives or making sure people can't
say mean things about them and to put my
cards on the table the only truly mean
thing i have to say about elon musk is
that men who get hair transplants or
sellouts and there is no room for
self-hating bald men in my circle now
you might be thinking elon isn't like
the other billionaire boys because he's
not buying a newspaper or cable news
network to reinforce his own ideological
agenda he's just purchasing a demented
global town hall where he'll sit back
and let everyone express whatever views
they want 280 characters at a time and
while we get where you're coming from in
another sense the fact that musk isn't
simply buying a paper or media network
makes things even more extreme that's
because he's not just buying a media
source he's buying the place where a
majority of news media and information
is posted and distributed in other words
he might not be buying a newspaper but
he's purchasing the proverbial digital
printing press and distribution networks
used by every news and media company
along with basically every writer and
journalist on the planet and in doing so
he's going beyond the trend of members
of the ruling class owning media
companies as pet projects and to
understand what this means we need to
talk about something called platform
capitalism to understand what it is
let's start with the first part
platforms while they are sometimes
places you can stand while you wait to
catch a train to a magical school of
wizardry these days platforms usually
refer to apps and websites like uber
airbnb and facebook as the book platform
revolution puts it a platform is a
business based on enabling
value-creating interactions between
external producers and consumers
providing an open participative
infrastructure for these interactions
and setting governance conditions for
them or as theorists and academic nick
cyrnic puts it what are platforms at the
most general level platforms are digital
infrastructures that enable two or more
groups to interact they therefore
position themselves as intermediaries
that bring together different users
customers advertisers service providers
producers suppliers and even physical
objects and unlike say a newspaper which
is a physical product that can be sold
for profit platforms don't really create
anything of value at least not in the
traditional sense according to cyrnic by
providing a digital space for others to
interact in platforms position
themselves so as to extract data from
natural processes weather conditions
crop cycles etc from production
processes assembly lines continuous flow
manufacturing et cetera and from other
businesses and users web tracking usage
data etc they are an extractive
apparatus for data so while old school
billionaires might have used their media
companies to push their own views and
agendas onto media consumers new school
billionaires like musk use platforms
like twitter to extract data from those
of us who use these platforms in this
way we can see musk's acquisition of
twitter as evidence of what writer and
professor jill lapore refers to as
muskism or extreme capitalism as lipour
sees it a childhood of reading and
according to a recent video on this
channel misreading science fiction has
led musk to favor a sort of capitalism
which is more theoretical than
industrial as she describes it i think
it is an extreme form of capitalism in
the sense that it's plutocratic it's
something old again there's a lot of
feudalism in muskism it's like there are
these lords and the rest of us are the
peasantry and our fates are in their
hands because they know best and the
idea that musk's brand of capitalism is
sending us back towards feudalism caught
on quickly after he announced his
purchase of twitter with people
expressing concern that with musk in
charge every time we tweet we'll
actually be doing free labor on musk's
digital land but cyrnic questions the
argument that posting is equivalent to
doing unpaid labor he says that free
labor is only a portion of the multitude
of data sources that a company like
google relies upon economic transactions
information collected by sensors in the
internet of things corporate and
government data such as credit records
and financial records and public and
private surveillance such as the cars
used to build up google maps so even
when we're not actively posting if
that's something you're capable of we're
still creating data simply by existing
or being alive in our largely digital
economy we're creating data basically
all the time cyrinic goes on to further
disconnect posting from traditional
labor beyond the intuitive hesitation to
think that messaging friends is labor
any idea of socially necessary labor
time the implicit standard against which
production processes are set is lacking
this means there are no competitive
pressures for getting users to do more
even if there are pressures to get them
to do more online while a feudal laborer
couldn't really choose to not work their
land we can choose to put our phones
away and not post so the good news seems
to be that when you tweet at your
favorite director giving them your notes
on their latest release you're not
technically doing free labor for musk
the bad news is that no one is forcing
you to tweet other than yourself but
labor or not he's collecting a
ton of your data like you know that
you're watching this video right now
in your house but let's get back to the
negative reactions to musk's twitter
acquisition much of the anger seem to be
based on the idea that people enjoy
using twitter but they don't enjoy the
person of elon musk and thus musk's
acquisition of twitter means they will
now enjoy it less sort of like if some
dude who bullied you in high school
bought your favorite sandwich shop and
now every time you bite into that turkey
pesto sub you can almost taste the
toilet water he used to dunk your head
in for others it seems that they worry
that musk will somehow impose his
personal political views whatever they
are onto the platform in some way and
this isn't an unfounded worry as
according to cyrnic platforms are also
designed in a way that makes them
attractive to its varied users while
often presenting themselves as empty
spaces for others to interact on they in
fact embody a politics the rules of
product and service development as well
as marketplace interactions are set by
the platform owner though as of the
writing of this script the main changes
he's discussed are charging brands and
larger accounts for quote tweets
potentially monetizing viral tweets as
well as the addition of an edit button
but for many it simply seems to be the
case that elon musk owning a popular
platform is crossing some type of moral
boundary but that worry also seems to
imply that up until now twitter was
owned by the good guys and who are those
good guys well until musk takes over the
majority shareholders of twitter are
morgan stanley investment management the
blackrock group vanguard funds and some
saudi investors none of these dudes have
ever been accused of being too woke and
blackrock was at one point the world's
largest investor in coal plant
developers and is currently one of the
world's largest investors in weapons
manufacturing i mean say what you will
about elon but at least the dude is more
into batteries than coal and rockets
that go into space more than rockets
that accidentally hit hospitals full of
civilians so what makes elon musk any
better or worse than those companies or
for that matter the owners of meta
google amazon or any number of prominent
digital platforms some of the outcry
seems to come from a genuine desire for
a version of what we could call ethical
capitalism or ethical consumerism where
our money and in the case of twitter our
time and attention is spent supporting
brands and companies that share our
values this mentality has been on the
rise in recent years and is particularly
prominent amongst millennials there are
even financial funds that specialize in
investing money in companies deemed to
be adequately ethical and or
environmentally friendly this attitude
looks like someone who won't eat at
chick-fil-a because their owners have a
history of funding
anti-lgbtq organizations but who will
eat at chipotle because of their
commitment to sourcing sustainable and
organic ingredients but just like you
can't bang your way to virginity some
would argue that you can't capitalism
your way to an ethical society it seems
like the phrase there is no ethical
consumption under capitalism is becoming
a crucial proverb for our times the idea
here is that if we apply the standards
of individual ethics and morality to
capitalism which functions according to
economic and not moral logic we'll be
consistently let down much like the
recent controversy around joe rogan's
deal with spotify which similarly led
users to proclaim that they were leaving
for other digital streaming platforms we
see these contradictions when people
want brands to share their ethics in
politics and it's not hard to see the
contradictions at play when companies
attempt to convince consumers that they
are in fact doing ethical stuff for
example recently blue bottle coffee
started piloting a shift to make oat
milk their default milk for the purposes
of reducing greenhouse gas emissions
that come from dairy production which
seems great until you realize the blue
bottle is owned by the nestle
corporation who along with being a
generally very very bad company they
literally did child slavery also has a
full-on dairy division so even if you
feel good about your oat milk latte
you're also giving money to a company
that was sued for and i cannot repeat
this enough doing child slavery it's not
handmade in usa it's pronounced handmade
and usa the honda people are a
vietnamese slave tribe and usa is their
island prison they
made your jeans you know how they get
the stitching so small
orphans on the other hand there are
those who might say it's unethical to
eat things like fast food due to things
like food quality environmental impact
and labor conditions and that it's bad
to eat factory farmed and non-organic
meat and produce again for environmental
impact and working conditions but what
does that mean for people who can't
afford organic grass-fed chicken breast
or gluten-free cashew mac and cheese are
they to be held morally responsible for
their consumer choices or are they
simply doing whatever they need to do to
survive in a system that isn't providing
a lot of other options if you can afford
to patronize companies that treat the
planet and workers well that's great but
if you can't you shouldn't be held
morally responsible for systemic issues
that you have no control over which
brings us back to the question of
whether or not elon musk is going to
ruin twitter and of leaving the platform
is a useful response for folks who don't
dig elon's whole libertarian space
pirate who is also an online
psychopharmacologist 5. so if people
decide to leave twitter where will they
go if you're able to simply abstract
yourself from social media altogether we
have nothing but the deepest love and
respect for you but for those who are
dependent either socially or
professionally on social media platforms
where might you go if the worst guest
host in the history of snl succeeds in
buying twitter maybe you head over to
instagram or facebook well they're both
owned by meadow which is the brainchild
of this guy and if you find him to be a
significantly better person than musk
there you go but maybe you're not into
zuck's misinformation happy platform
either so you're gonna park your digital
self firmly on tiktok oops well they're
owned by chinese company bite dance
which has been accused of censoring and
surveilling content on behalf of the
chinese government which
is not the best so maybe you go over the
platform not connected to global
corporations and find some new friends
on craigslist missed connections what
are you trying to do get yourself killed
the point is it's pretty hard to fully
disconnect ourselves from companies that
vary from kinda sketchy to literally
doing human rights abuses because
platforms of all types have become
inextricable for modern life so unless
you want to go fully off the grid you're
going to have to navigate some type of
relationship to platforms owned by
people with names like mark jeffrey and
yes even elon and we're not saying it's
good that musk is buying twitter but we
are saying that moral categories like
good and bad aren't the most useful
metrics to apply to platforms whose sole
purpose is the extraction of data for
the sake of profit asking a platform to
be moral is like asking a couch cushion
to be delicious musk's reign as ceo of
twitter might be bad it might be good it
will almost definitely be weird but one
thing we do know for sure is that he
isn't the only super rich person who
sees value in owning a platform whose
sole purpose is the collection of
monetizable data and as more of our
social and professional lives get
inextricably linked with these platforms
we're all kind of stuck here whether or
not we continue sharing our flaming hot
takes on twitter every time we drink too
much caffeine but what do you all think
is elon going to destroy the peaceful
twitter community we've come to know and
love or is the reaction to his recent
bid overblown let us know in the
comments hit that subscribe button like
you're launching your high school bully
into deep space on a spacex rocket and
don't forget to ring that bell
thanks to our patrons for all your
support and be sure to check out our new
patreon perks and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you